let's take some phone calls our phone
number is 617-830-4750
i believe we have our first caller of
the day here uh name in town and then i
i would love to answer a question for
you
is this the dave batman show this is the
david pakman show yes
oh hi
i'm a big fan of your work
thank you okay what's your name and
where are you calling from
uh my name's christina i'm from texas
excellent and what can i answer for you
today christina
um
i'm i'm i'm in college at the moment i'm
actually at school okay and i almost
wonder if you have any advice for
someone who
you know what the madness that college
has campuses do you have any advice for
someone like myself which madness now
this is interesting which madness are
you referring to because we've talked
about a lot of stuff going on on college
campuses
you know like the trigger warnings and
safe spaces i haven't gotten experienced
that yet in my college yeah but i'm in
community college at the moment so well
listen if you haven't experienced that
then maybe you don't need advice on how
to deal with it you might be uh in the
group that is that is not going to have
to deal with that although i get what
you're saying that maybe it's a little
bit different at a community college so
do you feel like you need trigger
warnings
i feel like i don't but i feel like it's
everywhere it's been everywhere and i'm
thinking well are
isn't college supposed to be a place to
learn things not a place for
you know the trigger warnings and space
cases that's my sense but let me ask you
this have there been any instances where
you were either shown a movie or a story
was told or literature was presented or
something
that and i don't want to use the word
triggered but that certainly reminded
you of maybe a negative or traumatic
experience i mean did you experience
anything like that
um not some not i can think of okay all
right well i mean i think it would be
interesting it would be interesting to
talk to someone not not that your
question is in any way invalid christina
but it would be interesting to talk to
someone who
did experience a quote triggering
but still recognizes for example that
that may actually have been a sort of
necessary part of the college experience
in order to prepare them for the real
world so my advice to you christina
would be it sounds like you've made one
good choice in terms of where to go to
school but just just be ready for the
fact that this is something that
sometimes happens on college campuses
although by and large the good news is
the individual professors i've spoken to
anecdotally
seem to sort of be of the more
liberally minded mentality that hey
we're here to teach the way we see fit
and that the safe spaces and trigger
warnings can sort of get in in the
middle of the relationship between the
professor and the student i think most
of the professors get that and it's
often because of sort of bureaucracy and
administration that they get wrapped up
in the trigger warning and safe space
stuff but please call back if you do run
into one of these instances specifically
oh thank you i was just wondering
because
i my professors are okay they're not
they're and i think they kind of are
aware of this stuff like this yeah so i
didn't joke with my professor like if it
has anyone been offended yet like i
think i can understand that he's kind of
aware with
with this type of behavior oh that's
interesting has anyone been offended yet
yeah all right well listen i we do have
to move on i thank you for the call
really really appreciate you uh watching
listening to the show in texas uh we'll
talk to you soon thank you okay we are
taking calls